What drove Sophia Bush and Chad Michael Murray
apart after they fell in love on the set of
One Tree Hill?
Which classic sitcom star celebrated her on-screen
husband's death with a round of champagne?
Keep watching, and all will be revealed.
Before he was known as that guy who starred
in all those religious films, Kirk Cameron
broke big as Mike Seaver on the ABC sitcom
Growing Pains.
Alas, when he converted to Christianity near
the end of the show's run, he became a holy
terror.
There are differing accounts of what exactly
went down between Cameron and his co-star
Julie McCullough, who played Julie Costello,
but it's clear that neither one liked the
other very much.
There are two different versions of the story,
though everyone besides Cameron tells the
same one.
In a 2017 interview with Wingman Magazine,
McCullough claimed that Cameron had her removed
from the show because she'd posed nude in
Playboy, which went against his newfound faith.
He gave her an ultimatum, and that proved
to be the end of her run.
Cameron has never spoken publicly about the
incident, but he was quite controlling on
the set, which he admitted to in an interview
with CBN.
At times, he even forced writers to rewrite
scenes that he deemed immoral.
"When you make a decision, like, 'I'm not
comfortable saying that line or doing that
scene,' well, that meant that 11 writers had
to come up with a new scene."
Furthermore, he confessed to the Los Angeles
Times in 2000 that he cut off contact with
his Growing Pains castmates for quite some
time, so it's not too hard to believe that
he used his clout to kick someone off the
show.
As for McCullough, her Twitter feed makes
it quite clear that she's still not a fan
of her former co-star.
She called him out in 2017 for his words about
the victims of Hurricane Irma.
Ross and Rachel were the couple on Friends
that everyone couldn't stop talking about.
But when they were on one of their famous
breaks, Rachel tried to seduce Joshua, played
by Tate Donovan.
The two eventually had a brief relationship,
but Joshua's arc is mostly remembered for
the incredibly cringeworthy ways in which
Jennifer Aniston as Rachel tried to seduce
him.
The writing made it uncomfortable, but there
was another factor at play behind the scenes
that made their relationship even more awkward.
Aniston and Donovan had been a couple in real
life, and they'd just broken up when he got
the call to appear on Friends.
He thought this might be a healthy way to
move past the relationship, but he soon discovered
that the opposite was true.
In a 2013 interview with HuffPost Live, he
admitted that filming romantic scenes with
his ex was "horrible," while also noting:
"I remember just getting back to my dressing
room and just weeping."
Donovan may have been able to laugh about
it while looking back, but it was clearly
a bad experience for him at the time.
Charlie Sheen isn't exactly known for an even-tempered
demeanor.
He was famously fired from Two and a Half
Men in 2011 following a series of bizarre
comments and behavior, and he quickly made
enemies on his follow-up show as well.
FX decided that they could make some money
with a sitcom starring Sheen, so they hired
him for the aptly-named Anger Management.
Working alongside Sheen was Selma Blair, who
played his therapist and part-time lover Kate.
Alas, Sheen immediately got up to his old
antics, including showing up late and being
unprofessional on set.
When Blair brought the issue up, Sheen turned
on her.
As one insider told E!,
"[He] went full throttle into getting her
off the show immediately."
Unsurprisingly for a Charlie Sheen vehicle,
the environment on set was described as "awkward
and toxic for everyone."
The real kicker was that Blair reportedly
found out that she was fired via text message.
Sometimes, co-stars hit it off right away,
only for their relationship to gradually deteriorate
over time.
But fortunately, Nina Dobrev and Paul Wesley
experienced the complete opposite when they
starred together on The Vampire Diaries.
Dobrev played Elena, who was in a love triangle
with Paul Wesley's Stefan and Ian Somerhalder's
Damon.
Alas, Dobrev and Wesley clashed immediately.
They both stayed quiet about it at the time,
but they've talked about it in the years since.
During a 2019 appearance on the Directionally
Challenged podcast, for example, Dobrev explained,
"There's a fine line between love and hate,
and we despised each other so much that it
read as love."
Wesley seconded these thoughts in an interview
with Entertainment Tonight, as he admitted:
"Creatively, it just wasn't in sync."
Thankfully, this story has a happy ending.
The timeline of their reconciliation is a
little wonky, as Dobrev says it only took
a few months, while Wesley claims it took
a few seasons, but regardless, they eventually
became friends.
They only have praise for each other now,
with both saying that they talk regularly.
"Now, I just adore her.
She adores me."
Pretty much any fan of The X-Files knows that
despite Mulder and Scully's crackling chemistry
on-screen, the actors who played them didn't
get along off-screen.
David Duchovny and Gillian Anderson played
the famous FBI agents on the Fox drama, and
their characters eventually went from professional
partners to romantic pair, to the delight
of legions of viewers.
However, working that closely with one other
person for years can lead to some struggles,
which Duchovny talked about in a 2008 interview
with Metro.
At that point, he was able to look back fondly
on his time on the show, and he even compared
Anderson to a sister.
However, he also said that "familiarity breeds
contempt," and the two simply got sick of
working together, though he insisted that
it had nothing to do with her specifically.
The intense shooting schedule and serious
subject matter led to petty arguments, and
Duchovny explained that it got to the point
that he and Anderson, quote, "couldn't stand
the sight of each other."
Thankfully, this is another story with a happy
ending, as the two reunited for an X-Files
reboot in 2016, and they'd clearly gotten
past any animosity, particularly if their
interview on Jimmy Kimmel Live! from that
year is anything to go by.
"These are people that get along, the two
people that I'm looking at right here."
"Uh, go on."
Before there was Ross and Rachel or Mulder
and Scully, TV's ultimate will-they-or-won't-they
couple was Maddie and David on Moonlighting,
who were played by Cybill Shepherd and Bruce
Willis, respectively.
Fans tuned in every week to see them solve
cases and flirt with each other.
Unfortunately, like so many TV couples with
unresolved romantic tension, things quickly
went downhill after they resolved it.
In 2005, Shepherd told Entertainment Weekly
that Willis was great to work with at first.
As she put it,
"With Bruce, the temperature in the room went
20 degrees higher.
For me, anyway."
However, over time, the two of them simply
began to hate each other.
She blamed the mutual dislike on the show's
"volatile" nature, but their co-star Curtis
Armstrong has claimed that there was more
to the story.
As he wrote in his book Revenge of the Nerd,
"[Bruce] intimated to me that there had been
one disastrously ill-conceived 'thing' between
him and Cybill, early on in the show's run.
While not going into explicit details, he
made it clear that that kind of mistake was
one I should be sure never to make."
Fortunately, though, Willis and Shepherd eventually
decided that their grudge should die hard
with a vengeance, and they even reunited at
his Comedy Central Roast in 2018.
Acting alongside someone you've recently broken
up with is one thing, but acting alongside
your ex-husband who cheated on you is another
entirely.
Alas, that's exactly what Sophia Bush had
to do on the teen drama One Tree Hill.
She played Brooke Davis, who was in a love
triangle that also involved Chad Michael Murray's
Lucas Scott.
At first, the romantic tension between the
two boiled over happily into real life, as
Bush and Murray quickly got engaged and married,
but it all came crashing down almost immediately.
The couple said "I do" in April 2005, but
then they split up in September of that same
year.
On a 2006 episode of Ryan Seacrest's radio
show, musician Nick Carter alleged that this
was because his ex-girlfriend Paris Hilton
had an affair with Murray.
Unfortunately for Murray and Bush, they had
to continue working on One Tree Hill together
until it came to an end in 2012.
Bush has since tried to avoid talking about
the incident, but when it did come up during
a 2021 episode of the Inside of You podcast,
she explained,
"I'm not going to talk about him.
I'm not allowed to because I've tried to poke
fun at being a dumb kid and whenever I've
done that, it gets twisted.
[...] It's not worth my time.
It's not a place where I harbor ill will or
anything."
Similar to Mulder and Scully, Richard Castle
and Kate Beckett were professional partners
who also had fantastic romantic chemistry.
The Castle leads eventually became a couple
and started a family as the seasons went on,
but the relationship between actors Nathan
Fillion and Stana Katic was apparently not
quite as rosy.
Neither actor has publicly addressed the working
relationship directly, but an insider told
Us Weekly in 2016 that things were indeed
quite difficult on set.
Fillion was reportedly so harsh to Katic that
she would cry in her dressing room, and the
two were apparently even forced to attend
counseling sessions together.
The show ended in 2016 after eight seasons,
but her departure from it was quite messy.
First, it was announced that her contract
hadn't been renewed, and then ABC announced
that the show was ending.
In a 2018 interview with Entertainment Weekly,
Katic addressed her departure by noting,
"It hurt and it was a harsh ending."
However, she did also claim that she was still
overall thankful for the experience.
Sitcoms wouldn't be what they are today without
I Love Lucy.
Lucille Ball was of course the star of the
show, but her co-stars Vivian Vance and William
Frawley, who played Lucy's neighbors Ethel
and Fred Mertz, were also a big part of what
made it so great.
The always-bickering couple had fantastic
chemistry, but the fighting didn't end when
the cameras stopped rolling.
Vance was only two years younger than Ball,
but she was playing the wife of a man more
than two decades her senior.
According to the book Meet the Mertzes, Vance
admitted,
"I loathed William Frawley and the feeling
was mutual.
Whenever I received a new script, I raced
through it, praying that there wouldn't be
a scene where we had to be in bed together."
Frawley in turn didn't have very nice things
to say, as he quipped,
"She's one of the finest girls to come out
of Kansas, but I often wish she'd go back
there."
According to an oft-repeated story, which
was recorded in the book The Dead Celebrity
Cookbook, Vance was at a restaurant when she
learned that Frawley had died.
Upon hearing the news, she ordered champagne
for everyone.
Whether or not this story is true, it accurately
sums up the hostile working relationship between
the two.
Martin Lawrence is no stranger to controversy.
His infamous Saturday Night Live monologue
in 1994 reportedly got him a lifetime ban
from the show, for example.
His sitcom Martin, which ran on Fox from 1992
to 1997, was popular, but also not without
controversy.
A big reason for the show's success was Lawrence's
chemistry with Tisha Campbell, who played
his wife Gina.
Alas, things were much rockier when the cameras
weren't rolling.
Campbell left the show in the fifth season
and brought legal action against Lawrence
for "repeated and escalating sexual harassment,
sexual battery, verbal abuse and related threats."
The case was ultimately settled out of court,
and Campbell returned for the show's finale.
However, since Lawrence wasn't allowed to
be around her when she shot her scenes, it
made for an awkward conclusion.
In the 2020 interview with GQ, Lawrence claimed
that the sexual harassment, quote, "didn't
happen."
Meanwhile, Campbell revealed on an episode
of The Talk that same year that due to the
settlement agreement, she isn't allowed to
speak about the matter in much detail.
If you or anyone you know has been a victim
of sexual assault, help is available.
Visit the Rape, Abuse & Incest National Network
website or contact RAINN's National Helpline
at 1-800-656-HOPE (4673).